I got accused of being racist last show
because there's a woman in the front row
and I said what's the deal with come on
the virus but you asked me because I'm
Asian and I'm like yes yeah it's not a
fat white guy problem as it yet you seem
somewhat responsible her boyfriend was
sitting Nestor I'm like who you vote for
dude he's like Andrew yang I'm like
buddy you're already [ __ ] her down
have some self [ __ ] is fast Jesus
Christ a lot of people like that mayor
Pete guy who's running yeah well you
know he's in the CIA but I don't think
[Music]
chase Ben
and he's president he'll definitely be
like I want a pin a medal on the first
non-binary person to commit a genocide
to long genocide has been
[Music]